Yo
fait que
2è vidéo
euh deè vidéo de la de la de la chaîne.
Écoute, on est rendu euh bon, on est
rendu what ? On est pas rendu, on est
juste
Je me demandais quelle vidéo j'allais
faire. Je fais l'autre je fais cette
vidéo là back to back avec la première
que j'ai faite
euh qui parlait dans le sens de que
j'allais commencer les vidéos YouTube
même que ça allait pas avoir une bonne
qualité de vidéo
et que j'allais le prendre pareil parce
que je faisais à long terme
je me suis fait quelques il va arracher
si je le montre là en tout cas euh je me
suis fait une petite liste des choses
que je voulais parler aujourd'hui
euh pour cette première vidéo là et on
va parler des sales, on va parler des
ventes euh
vent B2B principalement parce que il y a
quand même une bonne différence entre
B2B puis B2C.
Euh après ça, ben
c'est ça principalement B2B
que on va se s'attaquer.
Euh puis la différence avec le B2C
aussi.
Biti, personnellement, j'en ai fait un
peu pas en business euh plus au niveau
de mon expérience en tant que travail de
d'étudiant, travail étudiant dans le
monde des bords. Je peux voir la
différence. Donc on va commencer avec le
B2C le classique. Ça c'est l'idée
générale que tout le monde a de la
vente.
Donc B2C
to customer donc la vente directement au
client.
Ben au la vente au
particulier monsieur madame tout le
monde tu vas vendre tu vas vendre de
quoi vendre tes services vendre ton
produit peu importe c'est la vente B2C
B2C
tu peux vendre
tu peux vendre n'importe quoi. Tu peux
vendre de la glace un esquimo si tu
veux. surtout si c'est quoi qui est
qui vaut pas hyper cher,
qui a pas nécessairement une grande
valeur, tu peux vendre de quoi que la
personne a même pas besoin. Par exemple,
j' on prend l'exemple de de la glace, un
esquimo,
ben que si tu utilises les bonnes
phrases, les bonnes questions que tu
poses, même pas même pas même pas de
question juste si tu dis les bonnes
choses au bon moment avec la bonne
intonation que tu dégages de la
confiance en toi, même pas même pas la
confiance dans la relation, juste la
confiance en toi de tu sais ce que tu
c'est l'image typique de
en mode
Lou Wall Street tuarrive et j'ai ça
vendre c'est la meilleure affaire sur
terre achète-le importe c'est pas grave
non j'ai j'ai deal je rajoute ça sur ça
puis là mon il est rendu malade on
l'achète puis on on fait on fait le deal
à soir on signe les papiers à soir ça
B2C ça peut fonctionner
vente de char
vente concessionnaires d'aut ça se fait
encore aujourd'hui comme
Ça ça dépend, je généralise mais il y en
a beaucoup qui c'est comme ça qui s'y
prennent d' concessionnaire quasiment de
la vente à pression, tu sais. Tu vas
aller pousser toute l'information
directement au client. Tu dones tout, tu
garoches puis euh tu espères que ça va
fonctionner. Après ça, si il te s'il dit
quelque chose qui a qui a pas passé, ben
là, tu vas aller dire tes
tes réputations puis tu vas encore une
fois pousser pousser pousser. Même si
même si tu sais que la personne a pas
besoin, tu s'en fous.
Puis moi c'était ça dans le monde des
bords. Dans le monde des bords, j'étais
bon man.
Dans le monde des bars, c'est ça, c'est
vente à pression, vente à Tu sais que le
gars, il y en a pas besoin d'avoir un
verre de plus. Il y a pas besoin
d'acheter la bouteille à 300 400 pièces,
mais tu vas quand même aller pousser la
bouteille
même s'il y en a pas besoin.
Euh
donc là on va faire le bascule à B to
Business to business. Donc là, tu vends
soit un service soit un produit à des
entrepreneurs, donc au décideurs dans
l'entreprise.
La différence là, c'est que d'abord tes
services, ton produit, il est beaucoup
plus cher.
La personne avant de toi, elle a une
tête ses épaules parce que tuas des
décideurs qui ont une tête ses épaules.
Puis de plus en plus si tu montes en
aquet
donc tu dois changer ton approche
complètement. C'est pas du tout il y a
aucune pression qui se fait, c'est de la
compréhension.
Souvent quand tu t'informes sur la
vente, l'affaire qui revient souvent
c'est
un transfert de confiance.
c'est de dégager la confiance oui en
toi, en ton produit, en ton service,
mais de donner cette confiance là à ton
prospect à lui côté doit ressentir ça.
Donc ça ça va comment ? Ça va en posant
les bonnes questions,
poser les bonnes questions à ton
prospect,
le comprendre.
Tu peux utiliser des techniques de
d'écoute active. Donc la reformulation,
donc de reformuler ce qu' vient de dire
dans tes mots. Par exemple, ça crainte,
c'est le prix qui va être trop cher. Ben
ouais, je comprends. Euh vous vous euh
vous pensez que ça va être trop cher à
euh sur plusieurs mois, vous pensez que
vous allez perdre l'argent, ça va pas
être assez rentable pour l'entreprise où
il y a des risques justement ce soit pas
assez efficace, qu' a des erreurs qui se
font. Donc on va perdre l'argent.
Je comprends
de reformuler ce que la personne a dit
dans des mots différents pour la
personne se sente compris
puis ça augmente ton niveau de
confiance.
Là je dis tout ça moi il il reste
énormément de chemins à parcourir au
niveau des ventes. C'est vraiment pas
quelque chose que j'ai masturisé loin de
là. Les vent c'est un art.
Donc là je parle avec mon mon vécu, mon
début d'expérience dans les ventes de
B2B. Euh sinon je dire oui un de mes
mentors me dit
ça c'est un autre point qui quiembarque
avec la vente B2B principalement équipe
tu dois vouloir aider pour un vrai donc
de savoir
ton produit de savoir ton service de
savoir la valeur que ça va apporter dans
la vie de ton client de son entreprise
tu le sais que ça va apporter porter la
valeur à son entreprise. C'est pour ça
que tu es là pour lui. Tu es pas là pour
lu pousser de toi dans la gorge qu'il y
a pas besoin. Non, tu es là pour lui
pour lui démontrer, pour lui donner la
confiance que on est là pour l'aider
pour de vrai avec une solution de
qualité.
Euh aussi chose que j'ai appris 3è point
récite pas un pitch rite pas
c'est sûr qu'au début ça va être ça.
Moi, j'étais stressé au début quand j'ai
commencé vraiment pas aujourd'hui. Et ça
m'arrive des fois d'être des journées
moins moins dedans puis tu vas être plus
robotique donc de tu vas résister si on
te dit tu vas résister
tu vas résister au final tu vas être
robotique puis ça au final c'est tu vas
aller te rapprocher de la vision typique
du vendeur. Puis ça surtout en B2B
même B2C quand tu fais un quand tu
reçois un feeling de vendeur
tu coupes les ponts direct avec la
personne la personne ça l' cœur d'avoir
un vendeur dans lu vie le typique
vendeur ça l' cœur. Donc tu dois
vraiment t'éloigner de ce ce feeling là.
Ben cing là ce
mental là de
rester un script, c'est t'adaptes à la
personne, tu t'adaptes à son euh à
comment qui est à comment qui pense.
Ça va venir un autre point qui est le
miroir. Agir comme le miroir. On va on
va revenir pour une autre vidéo.
D'ailleurs, je vais me le noter. Mais
vous voyez, moi j' il y aura pas de il y
aura pas de montage là dans mes dans mes
vidéos là surtout pour commencer.
Donc moi si je prends une note j'arrête
ça va être
pour commencer dans peut-être dans les
prochaines vidéos il va avoir il va
montage mais c'est ça euh
ouais et puis ça rien à se mettre à la
place d'autres personnes. Puis un truc
je crois pour ça que moi j'ai découvert
que j'ai découvert comme si c'était euh
magique, non. Euh mais c'est juste de
méditer
ça aussi d'ailleurs et je vais en parler
de la méditation dans le monde des
affaires. Vous voyez, c'est comme un
brainstorm que je commence en faisant
les vidéos là. Mais méditation pour les
euh dans le monde des affaires très
important surtout pour la relation
humaine. Moi je le sens quand je t' en
vente puis que je ne
pas médité, je suis plus dans ma tête,
je suis plus fixé sur le outcome
de je dois booker, je dois closer, peu
importe.
Je fais assez focus sur est-ce que la
personne en a besoin, est-ce que
l'entreprise en a besoin ?
Puis je moins écouter la personne, je
vais moins me mettre à sa place, je
moins poser des bonnes questions. Puis
c'est là que la confiance va être
brisée.
Ça c'est un travail qui est continuel
qui continue qui continue, excusez-moi,
mais que tout le temps travailler
constamment.
Euh
puis ça ressemble à ça pour les points
que je voulais dire. Donc rapide, tu
dois vouloir aider pour de vrai la
personne. Tu dois poser les bonnes
questions.
Très important. Ré pas un script donc
pas être robotique pour dégager la
confiance. Mets-toi à la place de
l'autre personne
puis pour t'aider pour tout faire ces
points là. La méditation avant tes super
important
méditation puis
on pourrait parler aussi de
psychocybernétique
qui serait bien important à par aussi
d'autres vidéos donc c'était la deè
vidéo Donc yo.